[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLARA BAYARRI: Good afternoon!
Welcome to Best Practices
for Text on Android.
My name is Clara Bayarri,
and I'm a tech lead
on the Android Tool Kit team.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
I'm Florina Muntenescu,
and I'm an Android
developer advocate.
SIYAMED SINIR: Siyamed Sinir,
tech lead for Android Text.
CLARA BAYARRI: So why are
we giving a talk about text?
Well, it turns out text is
a major part of your app.
It's part of your design.
It's part of your branding.
It's part of who you are.
And it is the major thing that
your users will be consuming.
It is front-front, the first
thing that your users read,
and the thing that will
mostly affect readability,
accessibility,
usability, all of that.
On top of that, the
Android Text Stack
is responsible for
emoji, which we all love.
But all of this obviously
comes at a cost.
So there's a bunch of
performance implications
related to text that we
want you to be aware of.
So today we're going
to go through a bunch
of best practices and
things that you should know.
Before we can do
that, let's talk
a bit about the architecture.
We want to explain how the tech
stack is fitted within Android,
so that you can better
than understand what we're
going to talk about later.
The text stack on Android
is split into two parts.
There's Java code, and then
there's native, or C++ code.
At the very top
of the Java layer,
you will find the thing
that you're probably
most familiar with, which
is text view and edit text.
These are widgets that
provide text functionality out
of the box and do
everything for you.
If you have custom
views, where you
don't want to use our
widget, then you're
probably using the
second layer, which
is layout paint in Canvas.
This class is in Java
will help you lay out text
and render it without
actually using our widget.
Once we get into the native
part the very first layer
is a library we call Minikin.
Minikin helps us do word
measurement, line breaking,
and hyphenation.
And it is our first point
of contact with C++.
Below that, there's a bunch of
libraries we use to help us,
ICU, which deals with
Unicode, HarfBuzz, which
does tech shaping
for us, FreeType
which generates bitmaps
for all of the Gifs,
and finally Skia, which
is our graphics engine.
Today, we're going to
focus on the top three,
as these are the layers
that the Android team owns,
and the one we can provide most
best practices and hints into.
SIYAMED SINIR: Minikin lies at
the core of Android Text Stack
and is implemented in C++.
Its main responsibilities
our text layout, measurement,
and line breaking.
It is important to understand
what parts are implemented
in Minikin versus
Java, as that defines
which features we can backboard
using support library, which
doesn't allow native code.
Let's start with
text measurement.
If you provide a string
like this to Minikin,
first it tests to
identify the glyphs.
Glyph is a representation
of a character.
And you can think of it
as the image to be drawn.
However, the correct
[INAUDIBLE] of glyph matching
is not always one to one.
Here, we have three letters,
FFI matching a single glyph.
Glyphs can also be found
in different fonts, which
is the case with the Japanese
character in the example.
This is called the
font fallback chain.
Once all the glyphs
are identified,
the system can
position them together
to have the final look.
However at this point,
positioning is not always
putting the glyphs
side by side, which
is the case with the
letter e and acute accent.
If you provide a longer
string, Minikin first
divide it into words.
And for each word, it
does the measurement.
The result of this measurement
is added into a cache
so that if the system comes
across with the same word
again, it can raise
the computed value.
This is a system wide
LRU cache, and has
a fixed size of 5,000 items.
Then the string is wider than
the array test [INAUDIBLE]
Minikin has to do a line break.
In the simplest case, this is
putting the boxes side by side
until the boundary is
reached, and then moving
to the next line.
The behavior is controlled with
the break strategy attribute.
And if you were to switch
from simple to balanced here,
Minikin will distribute the
[INAUDIBLE] among the lines
to have better text element.
The default value
is high quality,
which is very
similar to balanced,
except a few subtle differences,
one of them being hyphenation
for the last line.
Hyphenation improves the
alignment of the text
and the use of whitespace, and
it gets more and more important
as the line width gets shorter.
Although, this
comes with a cost.
The cost arises
because now the system
has to measure more
words and it has
to compare more configurations
for an optimum solution.
After Android P,
enabling hyphenation
is 2 and 1/2 times
more expensive
than the disabled state.
On Android P we improved the
simple break strategy case.
However, the default
configuration
still has the same cost.
Another thing that affects
hyphenations the locale.
In this example, we have a
device in the English locale,
and two example strings.
One of them is not
hyphenated correctly,
and the other one the
last use the right glyph
for the Japanese text.
This will mostly happen
for dynamically loaded text
such as these things
loaded from network.
And it happens because
the system is not
aware of the languages
of those strings.
To fix this, we have to tell the
system about the language using
the setTextLocale function.
If the string contains
multiple languages,
you can use LocaleSpan to mark
different parts of the word
string.
However, keep in mind that
the number of locale spans
affects the performance
of the text layout.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: One
of the most common tasks
when working with
text is text styling.
So usually we would start
working with the text
attributes and set text
excise, text color, and font.
So we call this a single style
because all of these attributes
effect the entire text
from the text field.
But usually for the
designer, this is not enough.
And they will want
to style specifically
one word or one paragraph.
So what they want is to apply a
multiple style to the same text
block.
So in order to achieve this
in Android we work with spans.
Spans our markup objects
that can be attached to text
from a start, tone, and index.
And spans can be categorized
into character and paragraph
spans, depending on whether they
apply to only a few characters
or to entire paragraphs.
And then characters spans
can be split into appearance
and metric affecting.
And the difference
between them lies
in the method that needs to
be called on the text view
in order to render the slide.
So appearance affecting spans
require a redraw to be called,
whereas metric
affecting spans require
both a remeasure and a redraw.
Let's see an example.
So let's say that we need
to style a code block.
So in order to do
this, first we would
change the background color.
So for this, we would use
a background color span.
This doesn't change
the metric of the text.
So this means this is an
appearance affecting span.
But we also need
to change the font.
So for this, we would
use typeface span.
But because fonts also
change the size of the text,
this is a metrics
affecting span.
To style blocks of
text by, for example,
changing the layout
margin or drawing
a bullet in front of the
text, would use a bullet span.
So paragraph spans,
like the bullet span,
have to be attached from the
beginning of the paragraph,
and affect the entire
text of the paragraph.
The thing is that if
you don't attach it
from the beginning of the
paragraph, well, chances are,
you'll lose the
styling completely.
So in the framework
we define a series
of interfaces and
abstract classes.
And under the
hood, the framework
checks for instances
of these classes,
and then triggers different
actions depending on them.
But actually what
makes spans so powerful
is the fact that they give you
access to things like the text
paints or the canvas, in the
case of some paragraph's spans.
So this means that you can
pretty much handle everything
you need in terms of text.
So first of all,
whenever you need a span,
check the ones that are
available in the framework.
Because they cover most
of the common use cases.
But if you go back
to our example,
we see that the typeface span
only gets a typeface starting
with Android P. So
this means that if we
want to support free
P devices, we want
to create our own custom span.
So to do this, we would expand
from metric affecting span.
And this class gives us
access to two methods.
To update measure
state, which is called
when textView
onMeasure is called,
and update draw state, which is
called when the textView onDraw
method is called.
And both of these methods give
us access to the textPaint.
So then in the textPaint
all we need to do
is change the type face.
But if we have the textPaint,
it means that we can also
set the background color.
So it means that we can
just create one code blocks
span to style our code block.
So now we have two different
ways of styling our code block,
one with composing
multiple spans,
one from the framework
and a custom one,
and another way where
we're using a custom span.
So which one should you use?
To help you decide, there's one
important piece of information
that you need to remember.
Only framework spans
can be parceled.
So there are two common cases
when the spans are parceled,
first, when we're
passing text via intense,
or when we're copying text.
Independently, for copying
text, for example, from a text
view to an edit text
in the same activity,
or whether we're copying
text from one application
to another, that text gets
to be parceled and unparceled
via the clipboard service.
So this is what will happen.
If we're passing the text with
one framework span and one
custom span, well, just our
framework spans our passed.
So this means that we're losing
our custom typeface span.
But then if we're passing a
text with one custom span,
that it means that no
styling will be kept.
So in general, when you
are implementing spans
and the text gets parceled,
consider the behavior you want.
Should the style be
partially kept or not?
CLARA BAYARRI: So now
that you know about spans,
how do we use them in text?
Well, the framework provides
two key interfaces for this.
The first one is Spanned.
Spanned is for immutable
tags and immutable markup,
and declares methods
such as get spans
or it get span start
and get span end.
It lets query spans,
but not modify them.
If you want to
modify them, we have
Spannable, which has
the ability to mutate
the markup with methods that
does set span or remove spam.
Then we have three
concrete implementations
of these interfaces.
The first one is SpannedString,
which implements Spanned,
and as such has immutable
text an immutable markup.
SpannableString, which
implements Spannable,
as such has immutable
text but mutable markup.
And finally, we
have a third class,
which adds mutability
to the text, which
is SpannableStringBuilder.
This is what we use
internally, for example,
for edit text, because
it allows you to modify
the text and the markup.
These last two classes are
very different internally.
SpannableString holds
an array of spans,
whereas SpannableStringBuilder
holds a tree of spans.
So these are widely
differently implemented.
So as a team, we were wondering,
well, is a tree more efficient?
Maybe there's a case where
we want to recommend people
to only use
SpannableStringBuilder
all the time because
it's more efficient.
So we ran tests.
The answer is up to 250
spans, they're the same.
They basically perform equally.
So we recommend you do what
makes most semantic sense,
which is use SpannableString
for immutable text,
SpannableStringBuilder
for mutable text.
However after 250 spans, they
really do start to diverge.
And we recommend you use
SpannableStringBuilder
for all of your cases just
because it is more performance.
Out of curiosity, we ran
these tests to the limit.
Turns out, when you
have thousands of spans,
they really diverge.
But we really, really
hope this is not
a common use case for anyone.
Another common thing
we see with spans
is people trying to
check if one span is
present within a spannable.
And the solution we've seen
online, uses span.getspans.
So it's something
like this, you just
query for all the
spans of a given type,
get an array back, and then just
check if the array is empty.
This is extremely inefficient.
You're going through
the entire span
looking for all of the
instances of that span,
collecting them
all into an array,
and then just checking
if that array is empty.
There's a better way to do this,
which is nextSpanTransition.
This method checks for
the boundaries of spans.
So when you ask for the first
boundary of a certain span,
it will just have to do the work
until it finds the first span,
and then it can stop.
And it won't collect any spans
into an array, wasting memory
that you shouldn't do.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
A frequent task
when working with
styling text is
styling internationalized text.
So usually in your
resources, you
will define the same string
in multiple languages.
But then you need to
highlight one specific word.
So here, for example, we want
the word text to be bold.
But the thing is that the
word and where it appears
is different in every language.
So one easy solution would
be to just use HTML text.
But the problem with
this is that HTML text
have limited functionality.
So if, for example, we
want to change the font,
this is not something
that HTML can provide.
The solution for this is
to use annotation tags.
So the annotation tag allows
us to set key and value pairs
and then define
whatever we need.
So here, for
example, I'm defining
the key font and the
value to be the font name.
And this is how we
would use it in code.
So we would get the
text from the resources
as a spanned string.
Then we would get the
annotations from the span.
We would [INAUDIBLE]
through them
and get the ones that have the
key that we're interested in,
and then the value.
And then it would set the
span based on the indices.
SIYAMED SINIR: We
will now look at how
text is laid out in the view.
Let's assume that
you have a text field
with some padding applied.
When you set the robot up,
text will reposition the image
to top of the view
after the padding.
Get compound
padding top function
will get only the distance
from top of the view
to bottom of the image.
Setting the drawable padding
with that extra spacing
between the image and the idea
that the text will be drawn in.
And now get compound
padding top will
point to this new location.
Then you set text.
Text we will create
a layout object.
Layout is responsible for
rendering and measuring text.
Here, the boundaries
of the layout
are highlighted in orange.
It will also provide you
some more information
about the text it contains
such as the baseline top
and bottom of the lines.
There are three layered
classes on Android.
BoringLayout is for single
style and simple text,
which doesn't contain
top, next line, or right
or left characters.
DynamicLayout is created for
editable and selectable text.
And for other cases, textView
will create a static layout.
When we set the
gravity, the layout
object itself will be
positioned in the view.
Get total padding
top will return
it a distance from top of
view to the top of the layout.
IncludeFontPadding.
This attribute will
add extra spacing
to top and bottom of the layout.
And the height of the
spacing is calculated
using the values in the font.
The effect is more visible
than you use a tall script.
In this example, when
it is set to false,
we see that the text is clipped.
Since it only applies
when you set to true,
it only applies to spacing to
top and bottom of the text,
on Android we will see
that lines will overlap.
On Android P we
fixed this issue.
Now if the system identifies
that the lines will overlap,
it will put extra spacing
between the lines,
and will apply this rule
to the whole paragraph.
To provide an opt
out option, we added
an attribute named
fallbackLineSpacing,
which is by default, turned on.
A similar attribute that
changes the line height,
is the elegant text
height attribute.
However, unlikely, even though
it changes the line height,
unlike the other attributes,
it will not add spacing,
but it will actually start
using a different font.
There are two different fonts
defined in the Android font
fallback chain,
compact and elegant.
Setting elegant
textHeight to do it
will make the system
choose the elegant version
of the same script
if that font exists.
Speaking of line height, it
is an important attribute
for the readability
of the text, and you
can't control it using
line spacing extra
and multiply it attribute.
These attributes will
add extra spacing
in between the lines,
but not the last line.
Since the developers
mentioned us,
that designers mostly
provide line night
as it is, but not as
multiplayer or extra.
On Android P, we added
the line height attribute.
Two other attributes that
we added on Android P
in order to bridge
the gap between design
and implementation are
FirstBaselineToTopHeight
and LastBaselinetoBottomHeight.
The first one will
let you control
the distance between
the top of the view
to the baseline
of the first line.
And the second one
similarly, will
let you control the distance
between bottom of the view
to the baseline
of the last line.
Finally, when you
set text alignment,
the text will be
positioned in the layout.
Get line left and get line right
functions of the layout object
will give you information
about this positioning
relative to the
layout boundaries.
Now that you know about layout
and some important functions,
we can answer a frequently asked
question on the internet, which
is how can you implement
a rounded background span?
This is not doable with Spans,
but we can draw it ourselves
using the layout functions.
To do that, first, we need to
mark our words that we want
to draw the background for.
Annotation, that
Florina mentioned,
is a good option
for such a use case.
Then we will define our
drawables, three for the words
that start and end on different
lines, and one for the words
that start and end
on the same line.
We will look over our own
annotations to find our words.
Then for each annotation, using
the start and end indices,
we want to learn
the line number.
And we can use get line
for offset function
of the layout, which will
convert the character
index into a line number.
For the words that start
and end on the same thing
we also want to learn about
the vertical coordinates
of the line.
We can get line up and get line
by them functions for this.
And finally, we
want to learn about
the horizontal
coordinates of the words
and get primary
horizontal function
to convert the correct index
to horizontal coordinates
relative to the
layout boundaries.
Now that we know the rectangle
that we want to draw in,
we can draw our drawable.
The other case,
where words start
an end on the different line
will have almost exactly
the same code, except now it
has to identify more rectangles
to the drawing.
CLARA BAYARRI: TextView goes
through the same three phases
that any view on Android goes,
measure, layout, and draw.
Measure is by far the most
expensive for textView.
Here is where we create the
layouts we just talked about
or recreate them if
we need to, and where
we decide on the width and
the height of the view.
This is really expensive work.
Later, and on layout, we
barely do anything, just
some scrolling and auto sizing.
And finally, in onDraw we
issue the drawing commands.
But measure is really,
really expensive,
and you need to be
very aware of this.
It's important to distinguish
what causes an onMeasure
with what causes an onDraw.
As Florina mentioned before,
anything that causes the text
to change in size
or how it needs
to be laid out, such as the
letter spacing, the typeface,
maybe that text size, that
will have to trigger onMeasure,
as we need to
recalculate that layout,
whereas if you change
something that just changes
the appearance, but not how we
place the text on the screen,
such as the text color
you're going to paint it in,
that only needs to
trigger an onDraw, which
is much, much cheaper than
doing an onMeasure as well.
Let's look at these
two phases separately.
So we have a textView like this.
I've set some text that
has several paragraphs.
And then I view spans to
style some of the words in it.
I've changed the text size.
I've changed the colors.
Well, the first option
to measure your text,
is there's method in
Paint called measureText.
A dead giveaway
of this method is
it takes a string,
not a spannable.
So what this will do--
paint just doesn't
understand spans.
So it will take the
text you've given it--
it doesn't understand
line breaking either--
so it will place all of the
text as one very long line,
ignore all of your
spans, and give you
the width of that text.
The next option is to use
kickstands, also from Paint.
Again, dead give away.
It takes a string.
So it will do exactly the same.
No line breaking, no spans.
It will place it all together.
And it will give
you the bounding box
of all of your glyphs,
which is a width and height.
It's important to notice
that these two methods return
slightly different values.
So textPaint.measureText will
return you the next advance
glyph.
This is where you will
position the next glyph
if you were to add another
one, whereas getTextBounds
will give you the bounding
box of the glyphs you have.
And these two values come from
different parts of the font.
So they may be very different.
If we want improve on
this, well, we use layouts.
Layout has a static method
called getDesiredWidth.
What this does is it
takes a text you give it.
It places each
paragraph into one line,
and taking into account
all of the styling,
it measures each of the lines.
And then it returns the width
of the longest line it has.
So it will give you the
width of the longest
paragraph you've given it.
This is useful to know how
much your text wants to be
before you can restrict it.
If you know the
width of your view,
well then you actually
create a layout object.
In this case, we've
created a static layout.
By having the constrained
width want to fit it in,
layouts can actually calculate
how to reflow the text,
and how to make it fit, and
give you a height in return.
So by giving it a width, we can
actually calculate the height.
On top that, as Siyamed
had mentioned before,
you will get a lot
more information out
of your layout object.
For each line, it will give
you things like the baseline,
the lines start,
the line end, so on.
We've measured the performance
of all of these methods
next to each other.
Measure text is the cheapest.
So compared to
measure text, you will
see that layout getDesiredWidth
and Paint getTextBounds
are quite cheap to run.
They are similar.
But once you get into
creating a static layout,
or once add text
view to measure text,
that gets more and
more expensive.
So now that you know what each
of these methods do, make sure
you use the one that makes
sense for your use case.
Similarly, we've talked before
about the word measure cache,
and how we measure words, once
and we place them in a cache.
Well for paint, when you call
measure text on the same word
a second time, turns out it only
cost us about 3% of the work
to return that value,
which is a huge gain.
So once we have a hit in
the cache, it's only 3%
of the work.
If we measure this in
text view, onMeasure
takes about 16%
to 11% of the work
that it did the first
time it sees a word.
So definitely using that cache
is really important for us.
So as I said several
times now, measurement
is really expensive.
What can we do about it?
Well in P, we've come
up with a new feature
called premeasured text.
The idea behind it is we
know that in onMeasure we
need to take all of the
glyphs, find them in the font,
place them next to each other,
and measure all of these words
that we will place in the cache.
So what premeasured
text does is it takes
care of this phase for you.
And you can run
this in any thread,
so that then once you
have that pre-calculation,
sending it on the text
view only takes about 10%
of the work that you
had to do initially,
which is a huge gain.
The way this looks in code is
we need a bunch of attributes
to know how to measure the text,
things like the font you're
going to use, the text size.
We have a convenience
method in text view
that will retrieve
all of these for you.
It's got text metrics params.
You can also build
this option yourself
if you don't have the textView
you are going to work with yet.
And then on a background thread
called precomputedtext.create.
This triggers all of the things
we've been talking about.
It measures each of the words.
It places them in
the cache, and it's
stores all of those values.
So this is also
useful if you're going
to measure more than 5,000
words, as this actually
stores all of the values.
Then once you have all of
this pre-computed information,
you can go back to the II thread
and set it on your textView.
Notice that all
of this only makes
sense if you know
your text beforehand.
If you just know your text
as you're going to render it,
do what we've always
done, because you're
going to be blocking
the UI thread anyway.
But if you do know
your text beforehand,
say you're loading
it from the internet
or you have an infinite
scroll, you can run this,
pre-computer all of your
text before it needs
to be shown on screen,
and the gain is literally
90% of the work will be done
on the background thread, which
is amazing.
Mention in Support Library
we do have a solution.
For P, we've just run this.
Between L and P, we can actually
not do exactly the competitions
that we've done, but we can
warm up that cache for you.
So that's what we do.
And then before L, sadly,
we can't do anything.
So it's a no up, but we do
have a solution in the support
libraries.
Another common thing we
see related to all of this
is very long text.
People tend to just say,
oh, I've got the text.
I'll just set it
all on the textView.
When you set text on textView,
it measures all of the words
and lays out the entire text
you've given it, even if you've
given us an entire book.
So this can be a
huge performance hit
if you're setting very long text
that then you're not actually
showing on screen, because
maybe the user never scrolls.
A solution to this is to split
your text into separate pieces,
say, for example,
paragraphs, and put them
all into a recyclerView
as different items.
Then this way while
the user scrolls,
we will start loading
the next bits,
but we won't actually
be triggering
a measure in a layout
of all of your texts.
You can also link this to
premeasured text, which
I just talked about,
and pre-measured all
of the background measurement.
Then you will have
all that information
really, really efficiently.
So we've talked about measure.
What about draw?
Draw is much
cheaper, but you also
have several options if
you're going drive yourself.
A easy one that people
tend to say, oh,
why don't you just
canvas.drawtext?
That's easy, right?
Turns out, canvas
does not understand
spans or line breaking
or any of the things
we've been talking about.
So similar to the things
were talking about before,
it will just draw
the text you give it
with no styling as one run.
Instead, if you have
styling, or if you
want to use line breaking,
again, use the layout classes.
You can see the recurring theme.
All of the layout classes have
a draw method that will actually
draw on the Canvas for you.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: I think it's
time we actually set the text,
but in a performance way.
So set text, I think is the
most commonly used method.
And it's great for text
views that don't change,
so when both the text and
the markup attached to it
are immutable.
So under the hoods, the textView
creates a defensive copy
as a spanned string.
So this means that
if you're changing
the original reference, the
textView doesn't update.
But what if we want to
mutate the spans later?
Or to do this, we
would send the text
using buffer type spannable.
So under the hood, the textView
will create a copy of it,
but as a spannable.
So this means that while
the text is immutable,
the spans are mutable.
So once what we
can do here is we
can get the text as a
spannable, and then we
can add or remove spans to it.
And I know that
you'll be tempted
to call tech or set
text again, but you
don't need to do this anymore.
Because textView has an
all span change listener.
And it automatically knows when
something was added or removed,
and the text will
just be displayed.
But what if you want to
change an internal property
of the span?
So in our case, we want
to change that typeface
in our custom typeface span.
Well, in this case, the textView
doesn't know what's changed.
And it doesn't know that
it needs to do something.
So we need to tell it.
And we will do this with either
request layout or invalidate,
depending on what kind
of attribute has changed.
So if you change the
measure affecting attribute,
and the textView needs to
remeasure and then redraw,
it would call request layout.
But if you just change an
appearance affecting attribute,
then you just need to
invalidate and call redraw.
But what if you also
want to mutate the text?
So if I look at the code,
we see that under the hood
the textView creates a copy
using a spannable factory.
So it has a default spannable
factory implementation.
But we can implement our own.
And then instead of
creating a copy of it,
we will just return the same
reference to the object,
in case the object
is a spannable.
And then we just set
that spannable factory
to the textView.
So this is
specifically important
if you're using style text
inside a recyclerView.
Because like this,
you avoid creating
copies inside the recyclerView,
saving both CPU time and memory
allocation.
So in the recyclerView, this
is how you would use it.
In the viewHolder, you would
set the spannable factory
you've just created, and then in
the onBindViewHolder, make sure
you're also setting the
buffer type as spannable
when you're setting the text.
CLARA BAYARRI:
Another common thing
we see related to recyclerView
is the use of autolink.
You might be familiar
with taking a textView
and just setting
autolink to say web
to be able to detect
URLs within your text
and have them
automatically linked.
Well, what happens under
the hood when you do this?
Turns out that when you set a
text on that textView, first
of all, we will create a
copy, just like Florina said,
and then we run a matcher
for a regular expression
on your text.
And for each match
where we find a URL,
we will create a URL span
and add that to your text.
If you do this inside
onBindViewHolder,
you're creating
copies, and you're
running that regular expression
every time you're setting text,
even if you're showing the
same text in each item.
So you have a little
footer with a link.
You're going to be recalculating
that for each and every item.
So the solution to this is one,
don't use autolink in your XML,
because that
automatically triggers
all of the process,
instead, first of all,
create a spannable
copy of your string,
and run either Linkify
or LinkifyCompat
to be able to find all
those links beforehand.
So you pre-calculate all of it.
And then in
onBindViewHolder, you simply
have to set the text.
And if you use Florina's trick
of using buffer type spannable,
you will be avoiding
all of those copies,
and avoiding all of
this extra computation.
Related to this, in general,
we want to discourage everyone
from using autolink map.
All of the other
options in autolink
use regular expressions
and are easy to run.
However, in map actually spins
off an instance of a web view
to find addresses, which
is a huge performance hit
for your app.
So we want to
discourage everyone
from using map or all,
which includes map.
And you might say,
well, but I need this.
And you're taking it away.
What do I do?
Coming to the rescue
is Smart Linkify.
You might remember last year we
presented Smart Selection in O
where we used machine learning
to detect entities when
you were trying to select text.
Well, this year, we've
taken those same machine
learning models that detect
entities and apply them
to Linkify.
This way, we can do a
much better accuracy
at detecting all
of the entities,
and we can detect new types.
So on top of phone numbers,
URLs, and addresses
like we're doing before, we can
do more sophisticated things
like flight codes.
The way this works in code is
you create a textLinks request
with your text, and it can
also take some options,
then on a background
thread, you call
textClassifier.GenerateLinks.
It's very important that you
do this on a background thread,
as this is loading a machine
learning model from disk.
So please don't do
this on the UI thread.
Once it comes back, it has
all of the detected entities.
You can apply those
links to the text.
There's a change here between
the old Linkify and this.
The old Linkify, it used
to generate a URL span
that when you clicked, it
would just go through the link.
And the case with Smart
Linkify, file the URL spans
that are being added
pop up a floating
toolbar with smart
actions that you can take.
So for example, for an
address, we might suggest maps.
Finally, when you have
all of your text ready,
you can go back to the UI
thread and set that text
on the textView.
Notice there's a big difference
between the old linkify
and the new linkify, and that
the old one was synchronous,
and this is asynchronous.
We understand this
is a huge difference.
But it is the way that we can
use machine learning to really
enhance how we detect entities.
And the accuracy
on the new models
is really, really much better.
And since I'm talking
about new features,
let me introduce
our last new feature
for P, which is Magnifier.
A lot of people tell us that
selecting text is really hard,
and placing the cursor where
you want is a really hard task.
So Magnifier shows
a zoomed in version
of where you are
touching with your finger
to help you place the cursor
in the correct position.
We've implemented this by
default in textView, edit text,
and in web view in Chrome.
So you don't have to
do any work if you're
using the default widgets.
However, if you're doing
your own custom widgets
and you want to
implement this yourself,
there is a very easy
API to use there.
You could do
something like this,
just take your untouched event.
And whenever the
finger goes down,
show the magnifier,
whenever the finger goes up,
dismiss the magnifier.
This creates an effect where
the magnifier kind of follows
your finger around the screen.
This is not the final
UX we've gone for.
We kind of snapped to the lines.
We will publish
guidelines on the final UX
we've come up with, but
it is very easy to use.
So I hope today we've presented
a bunch of tips and tricks.
We've shown you what text is
under the hood on Android,
and we've provided
more information
on how to style your
text so that you
can take all of this
back to your apps
and build beautiful
more performant apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]